c'est compliqué sérieusement toi toi tu
fais quoi ici temps bonne écoute je suis
venu pour chercher du travail
ouais et genre tu t'en sors bah écoutes
je suis dubitatif fils de [ __ ]
mais bon sait jamais au monde où ça la
petite copine
passe normalement
saleh comme chat ça va de lalbenque lot
bof
qu'est ce qui t'arrive
je me sens pas de ça vient mais j'ai pas
envie de vous prendre la tête avec les
problèmes du monde réel en ce moment les
mecs mais est on en retard pour la pile
un mois mais c'est morsay un passé qu'on
a du boulot il ya zéro chance qu'on
sorte
avec tapas de plus tu peux dire de
connard planqué dans le besoin à la
place de traîner tueur retourne bosser
au studio stoppait on savait même pas
qu'il y avait des buissons ici l'emploi
je suppose que tu habites pas dans le
caza fin d'année ça ressemble plus au
xvième siècle qu'au 16e arrondissement
c'est bon en culé tu peux nous dire tu
sors du placard